germany's covet crisis keeps escalating
the number of daily infections has risen
above the 30
000 mark for the first time that's just
days
after a record spike in the german death
toll which has been lagging the
infection numbers by several weeks
the country's second wave is also
threatening to swamp the country's
medical system
in the worst hit areas hospitals have
begun to transfer patients
to less severely affected places
a new covert patient has arrived by air
ambulance at freiburg's university
hospital
he's traveling in a special isolation
pod so none of the transport team gets
infected
the patient is only in his forties he's
transferred to vivian at zotzman's
intensive care unit
with five members of her team she turns
him onto his stomach
the prone position is an important
therapy for seriously ill covert
patients
the team makes sure the patient is well
padded as he will lie like this for
several
hours the inflammation
sits at the back of the lungs and a lot
of fluid collects there
the lungs can't heal if we lie on them
the whole time
by turning patients onto their stomachs
their lungs get air
and can heal
once a day the team turns each patient
onto their front
and back again it's a big effort
but proning and being put on a
ventilator is not sufficient for many
critically ill covet patients
some need to be connected to an
artificial lung to keep them alive
it pumps the patient's blood into a
machine where carbon dioxide is
extracted and oxygen added
the blood is then pumped back into the
patient's body
for patients who are this ill there
aren't many options left this is the
last trump card we've got
our therapeutic options are sobering we
give oxygen and the artificial lung
but that only gives us more time the
lungs have to heal on their own
in the hospital's pharmacy there's no
wander drug against the coronavirus
rem de sevier one of the great hopes at
the start of the pandemic
has yielded disappointing results as
have many other drugs
medics have fought the virus for nearly
a year now but the odds of surviving a
severe case
haven't improved much every second
person on a ventilator dies
behind each of those numbers is a human
being
in the second wave many young and
healthy people have also been infected
but that's no guarantee for a milder
cause of the illness
this is a young man 45 years old with a
severe case of covid
he's a prime example that a young
healthy person without any notable
pre-existing medical conditions
can be brought to the brink of death by
this virus
[Music]
the intensive care units really are at
the limit we have to be clear about that
there might still be some spare beds but
every day there's fewer
and patients lie here for a long time
for weeks or even months
and that means beds don't free up
quickly
at the moment they can still fight for
every single patient's life here
but the time after christmas could turn
into the intensive
care team's worst nightmare
to talk more about this we're joined by
hans brandt dw's political correspondent
hans welcome germany's infection rate is
at its highest since the beginning of
the pandemic
walk us through how that is affecting um
the country's healthcare infrastructure
well as we've just seen the number of
deaths is rising
very rapidly at the moment and in many
hospitals in germany
the limits are about to be reached or
have been reached already
that's especially true for areas in
eastern germany and the far east of
germany
which at the moment have the highest
infection rates in the country
these are rather remote areas where
hospitals are small and
their facilities are limited in that in
those areas people are being moved out
of those hospitals every day
normally by helicopter to other parts of
germany
where there are still beds available all
of the shifting around of patients is
happening
in many regions of germany at the moment
so the health system is under strain
it's not
over strained yet but at the same time
one has to say
over strained other people who are
working in these hospitals they've been
working very hard this is a
very often physically exhausting work
and many of them themselves
are either infected or so exhausted that
they can't work anymore
are german lockdown measures not working
or why do we continue to see
steadily increasing infections and death
suns
well we have to see that the infections
that we are counting now are people that
infected themselves maybe 10 days ago
and the people the deaths that us we are
seeing now are people that infected
themselves maybe three weeks ago
so there is a lag involved in this and
we have to say that the
measures that were in place ten days or
three weeks ago
were not sufficient they were not
working the more severe lockdown was
only imposed this week
but there is some hope as a result of
the
vaccinations that are about to start
with
a vaccinating agent that was developed
in germany
about which germany has which germany is
very proud of we have
a report about this let's have a look at
this report
biontech began as a small startup back
in 2008.
now the world's focus is on the vaccine
developer in mainz
one of its early backers the german
government
is pleased to be seeing a return on its
investment
[Music]
i can say it myself also as the head of
the federal government
we are incredibly proud that we have
researchers like this
here in germany it doesn't
co-founder er shaheen first read about
the coronavirus outbreak in china in
january
and predicted a global pandemic he
decided to redirect their resources from
researching cancer to finding a
coronavirus vaccine
it's a very exciting time when we get
the approval from the european
authorities
we can start delivering our vaccine
potentially even this year
our employees will work through
christmas to make sure that our vaccine
makes it to all countries
initially some four hundred thousand
doses will be kept for use in germany
if the eu gives the green light by the
23rd of december
vaccinations could get underway here by
the 27th
it's clear who will be receiving the
vaccine first
our primary goal is to protect people
over 80 years old
and those who live or work in retirement
homes or care facilities
the health minister says the rest of
society will have to wait their turn for
the vaccine
hans media reports are that
that spans vaccine roll-out plan
diverges
from the commission's recommendation
what do we know about that
yes the health minister will be signing
this uh regulation today and he has
confirmed that
in fact whereas the experts had
recommended six
groups uh six levels of patients that
or people that should be vaccinated he
has regrouped this into three groups and
the reason for that is that
he feels that is more flexible so you
don't have to
just finish vaccinating everyone in the
top groove before you can go one step
further down
so he feels that with this flexibility
the whole situation will be
more easy more easily
managed in this situation but the main
priority still remains with people that
are over 80 years old
and with people that are involved in
caring for
sick patients especially in hospitals tw
political correspondent hans brown thank
you very much
meanwhile the u.s has moved closer to
approving a second covit 19 vaccine
after an independent panel of experts
endorsed the shot made by pharmaceutical
company moderna
the decision paves the way for the fda
to approve emergency use of the vaccine
the u.s has already started its mass
immunization with a covet vaccine by
biontech pfizer the eu under pressure
now to follow suit said
it too would speed up its approval of
the moderna vaccine
a decision is now expected on january 6.
french president emmanuel macron has
tested positive for the coronavirus the
president's
office says it's highly likely that
mccall
caught the virus at a european council
summit last week
his diagnosis fuels alarm and anxiety
among europe's leaders many of whom had
close contact with macron at that summit
he also hosted spain's and portugal's
leaders in paris this week
both are now in quarantine
an affectionate squeeze that's how
french president emmanuel macron greeted
officials and heads of government
last week at the eu summit and how he
welcomed portuguese prime minister
antonio costa
to the elysee palace on wednesday
but now that macron has tested positive
for the coronavirus
those close contacts may wish they
dodged his warm embrace
last night the president started to
experience symptoms indicative of covet
19.
he immediately isolated and took a pcr
test the results of which confirmed that
he is positive for coven 19.
as for everyone who tests positive in
this country contact racing began
immediately in order to identify the
president's close contacts
macron's symptoms are mild he attended
this meeting virtually from isolation
but the positive test has upended both
his agenda and the agenda of european
politics
as the uk and the eu attempt to
negotiate a brexit trade deal
before the end of the year a growing
list of european leaders who met with
mack hall
are now working from home working that
is
unless they become seriously ill
in paris there was little surprise at
the president's misfortune
it's serious it affects everyone so no
there's no reason to blame him
it's obvious given his job that this
would happen so it doesn't surprise me
he probably didn't respect the social
distancing rules
macron joins a long list of world
leaders who have caught the virus
and just over a week before the eu is
hoping to begin vaccinations
let's take a look now at the latest
global developments in the pandemic
china is planning to vaccinate 50
million high-risk people
before the start of its lunar new year
at least four
chinese-made vaccines are in phase three
testing
a study in singapore suggests pregnant
women with covet 19 do not get more ill
than the wider population
the study also found that babies born to
infected mothers have
antibodies against the virus and
officials in australia have declared
sydney's northern beaches a coronavirus
hot spot
21 beaches will be closed because of a
spike in cases there
sydney residents are being urged to stay
at home